now if you have stiffness always
consider
the liver okay the liver if it's not
working right
will completely make your joints almost
you like you feel like you have
arthritis okay
and let's talk about why that is now the
number one point is you might have
something called
coleostasis okay coleostasis what does
that mean it means that your
bile is being backed up it's not flowing
through the pipes through the tubes
they're called
there's ducts okay like the bile ducts
and bile is supposed to flow freely
through there
but sometimes it gets thick and so you
have this combination
of too much cholesterol and not enough
bile and it's kind of just it gets all
jammed up and it backs up
and it creates a lot of inflammation to
the body now the bile is produced by the
liver
and it should drain through the ducts
and be stored in the gallbladder
and if there's a problem with these
ducts boy you're going to have pain and
primarily on the right side of your body
actually you're going to be stiff
and you're going to pain if you don't
have enough bile
also you're not going to absorb
and utilize vitamin d which is a very
powerful
anti-inflammatory right off the bat so
without vitamin d you're going to feel
kind of stiff you're going to have back
pain too
all right also the other fat cyber
vitamins are not going to be
available to you like vitamin k2 which
is also responsible of
transporting calcium from the blood into
the bone
so it doesn't deposit in your arteries
and your joints
okay so it keeps calcium in the right
place
so you might be deficient in k2 not
because you're not consuming is because
you don't have the bile
and also vitamin e that's another fat
soluble vitamin
and without vitamin e you can't counter
all the free radical damage that goes on
in the body
with your average diet also you're not
going to be able to absorb
omega-3 fatty acids and omega-3 are the
anti-inflammatory fatty acids
okay so right there you can see that not
having this bile flow that well
you can have problems with all of these
right here
all right so what's the solution just
start taking purified bile salts okay
i put a link down below of what i would
recommend
and you would just take this on an empty
stomach
take one in the morning and then take
one in the afternoon
and you can even take like two at a time
and so that way you're taking
four and that should open the ducts up
and if this is the problem you should
feel better
immediately like within like an hour now
parallel to this
to correct this problem you need to get
on something called healthy keto
and intermittent fasting okay because
that will ultimately
help your liver so then you can make
bile
cor and have it flow correctly through
the system healthy keto and intermittent
fasting
greatly improves a fatty liver and other
problems with the liver okay so i put a
link down below of
the program if you're not familiar with
it all right number two eliminate the
omega-6 fatty acids if you go out to
dinner a lot or you
eat junk foods you're consuming a lot of
omega-6 fatty acids
and that can be the reason why you are
stiff
this is why when people go out to dinner
they always stick these
like soy oil corn oil in the food and
then you feel stiff and you don't know
why
that's why number three start doing
fasting
fasting is one of the most powerful
things to repair
a damaged liver and if the liver is
doing better
your stiffness and joints will always do
better
and so if you learn about fasting you're
going to learn about something called
autophagy which is the
recycling of damaged proteins
like scar tissue in your liver and so
to clean that up is going to give you
more liver
function and less stiffness and pain
and this is a very important point let's
say it's not your liver
you just have osteoarthritis which is
different than
the autoimmune disease called rheumatoid
arthritis
osteoarthritis is mainly from old
injuries
okay um and it's a situation where your
joints
are wearing out because there's some
imbalance
in the mechanics of your joints so it's
wearing
more on one side than the other because
there's not symmetry because your body
is in this
guarding mode because of an old injury
because of compensation
okay i had a lot of that going on
here's what you need to know you cannot
have osteoarthritis
if there's a motion in that joint
correct
symmetrical motion you can't have that
arthritis
so the secret is to keep that joint
moving
and so there's a very very great
technique that i stumbled on that i'm
going to recommend
i don't teach it myself but you can find
someone in your area that teaches it
you can get this done remotely like a
one-on-one type coaching
there's books on it there's videos on it
but it's a great technique to keep your
joints
balanced and keep your joints from
turning arthritic and it's called the
august q
method okay so it's and i wrote down the
pronunciation because it's a little hard
to pronounce
ah goss q okay so i put a link down
below
on their website i'm not affiliated with
them but i think it's a very valid
amazing technique for those people who
have
pain chronic pain bad posture etc
all right guys thanks for watching this
video stay tuned for the next one
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you
how to bulletproof yourself and so you
can tolerate and resist your environment
much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today